مريم ما هي ردود فعل الدول حول الهجمات
الامريكيه والبريطانيه على اليمن طبعا فور
وقوع تلك الهجمات فجر هذا الجمعه خرجت
جمله من ردود الفعل والمواقف من دول عربيه
ودوليه جمله هذه المواقف وردود الفعل جاءت
مستنكره ورافضه لذهاب الموقف الى مزيد من
التصعيد في منطقه البحر الاحمر سلطنه عمان
استنكرت ما
وصفته لجوء الى العمل العسكري من دول
صديقه فيما تتمادى اسرائيل حسب وصف بيان
سلطنه عمان في حربها دون حساب اما الكويت
وعبر بيان وزاره خارجيتها فدعت الى خفض
التصعيد وبشكل فوري وتغليب صوت العقل دء
لايه اخطار قد تهدد الملاحه في منطقه
البحر الاحمر اما دوليا فقد دعت روسيا الى
منع تصعيد الوضع في المنطقه بعد الهجمات
الامريكيه والبريطانيه على اليمن وعبرت
الصين عن قلقها من تصاعد التوتر في البحر
الاحمر ودعت الاطراف المعنيه الى ضبط
النفس اما انصار الله الحوثيون فقالوا ان
كل المصالح الامريكيه والبريطانيه اصبحت
اهدافا مشروعه ردا على عدوانه ما المباشر
والمعلن